sir charles barkley welcome to the show
Charles thank you for having my brother
I really appreciate it it's great to
talk to you too we just watched Zion
Williamson do his deal and I know a week
ago you you had made some comments
around whether he was really the first
pick in the draft or not you kind of
maybe thought some other things
what is it been like to watch this young
man perform this year up down with the
injury and now performing the way he did
in the ACC tournament another one pick
in the draft it was amazing
an ACC tournament I mean he was
incredible
you know I it's been a pleasure to watch
I mean man he is just a fantastic you
know and people try to compare him to me
and I said no he's a lot more explosive
number one I think he's a little bit
bigger and I think he's more explosive
and man he just saw talented I mean he's
really talented it's been it's gonna be
I mean it's crazy our crazy played after
God playing basketball or only 12 months
to come back and playing like he did was
even more incredible is the comparisons
like you talked about I mean did you
look like that at 18 years old so much
more explosive than I was a lot better
but he's so much more explosive like you
know one nearly as good as you near this
you know I think he's got to work on it
because of the next level he's gonna
play it's coming interest on him and the
pros I'm not sure if he's a 3 or 4
that's what's gonna be very interesting
because you don't have some good matchup
in the pros at the 3 & 4 there's not
gonna be easy for him not if they're not
gonna be not gonna be easy to them
either well coming into this and gets an
approvable position they try to clam it
yeah
I'm interested to see how that plays out
- because it's really as you've taught a
lot of us and we when we watch the NBA
it's all about matchups and speaking of
that I kind of wanted to get into a
little bit of the the optics last night
with LeBron and being distanced in
distancing himself from the team during
the I mean these are things that that we
shouldn't even be talking about right
now this is a team that's not going to
be in the playoffs yet because of who he
is and the conversation that's always
surrounding him again there's something
that we have to talk about LeBron James
and and what the problem is in Los
Angeles well number one LeBrons not the
problem in LA obviously but you know the
Lakers screw this thing up from the
beginning when they bought in all those
old guys go with those young guys you
know you can't be like ours because I
said this is beginner season are they
trying to make the playoffs or they try
to develop these young kids you can't do
both I mean you got to see who we want
to keep going forward or are we trying
to make the club keep bringing all these
old guys so Lakers crew turnout from the
beginning as far as the things I'm
sitting on the bench it was not a good
look but LeBron knows there's a double
standard Ryan when you win again losing
you know I used to talk to Allen Iverson
was one of the greats
you know people complain about him not
practicing and things like that and I
said yo man you do know when you work
when practicing y'all will make it to
the finals or going deep in the playoffs
he didn't care but soon as things to
loosen but they gonna crush you that's
just how this thing is Ron people or
they're gonna take shots at you when
you're not winning it's nothing personal
these guys have to have something to
talk about all the TV for three or four
hours every day like I said I guarantee
if the Lakers won a number one seed for
the number two seed nobody said a thing
about LeBron said by ourselves I got it
but it did not look good but it didn't
look good cuz they're losing plain and
simple
why do you think it is imperative as a
culture or around organizations in
leagues that we that we can try to
compare the greatest of all time why why
do we continue to try to compare Michael
Jordan and LeBron James to different
eras to different players both great at
when they were what why do why is it
culture that we continue to do that do
you think well because you guys have all
this time on TV every day you know you
know around we're in the 24-hour news
cycle these guys need something to talk
about 24 hours a day so they make up
their storylines and it's all and they
always been a win-win situation what I
mean by that is if you start taking
shots at LeBron all the haters gonna
come out and take shots in the bar but
also all people who lined up are gonna
come out so that's how you keep three or
four hours of video going everyday in
these major markets I mean but you know
I the one thing I don't do I'll ever do
social media is never I think it's just
what idiots going to Boise opinion day
life sucks I mean I always say I think
most of those people just sitting around
their grandmother's house and moms out
in limited pairs they sit around in
their pajamas scratching their balls and
they gonna just take shots at people who
are successful and that's why I got mad
at Adam sent when he was talking about
social media why in the world was
somebody famous clear attention to
social media you winning in life you
know people gonna be haters good day
life stuff I don't understand why any so
governing or president successful I
stood around looking at the Internet
pretty good cuz I think about it if
you're successful you have time to
comment on other people you're actually
out doing stuff you've transcended all
of us Charles that's the difference the
the idea that what other people think of
you is none of your business is
clearly in that position I want to I
want to talk about that in particular
the reinventing yourself right you
reinvented yourself when you left the
NBA I mean how the transition is very
difficult for any professional athlete
to go from being this identity into
something new and I don't know if it was
seamless it seemed seamless for us
watching but talk to us about what that
transition was when you had to finally
leave the NBA and I know you were
involved with it in other things but
your life's taking on something
different into your point
you're not revolved around what other
people think of you but you're just
simply doing what you love to do
Yeah right you know my mentor Dick
Ebersol started talking to me my last
probably two years in the NBA he says so
you thought about anything you want to
do and think episode like him a lot of
credit for pointing me in the right
direction he says you know I really
think you should think about television
I'm like you're the most honest person
I've ever met he says no he said I think
he's gonna be great on TV he says but
you always gonna be in trouble
and I said what does that mean he says
you know when people tell you they
really they want to hear the truth they
really don't want to hear the truth you
know people want you that they want you
to tell them their tumors you're really
really good they want you to clear their
favorite player is great and that's all
fans care about and if you don't tell
them how great their team is or you
criticize their favorite player they're
gonna go crazy and that's the best
advice I ever got from dick up so he
said it he says listen you're gonna be
great on TV because but he says is there
more people wanted was a time than bad
but he said there's going to be a
faction of people players are also that
they're not going to like you that they
don't want to feel it they don't want to
choose
they want day they want you to tell them
what they want to hear and I made my
mind a long time ago I don't get
TV and tell the time some people don't
like it and some people don't kiss my
ass plain and simple
well it's been very inspiring for me for
somebody who's always struggled with
trying to be transparent and now with
that platform being able to do so I want
to transition a little bit here to the
n-c-double-a thing so you and I were
talking the other day about how you kind
of get sequestered here for the next 18
to 21 days and just upload the NCAA
bracket all the teams that are being a
part of it and and you know you go right
from the NBA to really not following the
NCAA until you get into this mix do they
just they just close the doors on you
for the next 21 days and hold you in
their feed you and put you on TV well
you know I have watched probably three
basketball games a day for the last two
months and we get a written report every
week on every college conference I mean
it's a lot of homework and I don't
always get your names and everything
right but the basketball is easy my god
like my mind when you're watching
college basketball I talked about the
coaches you can't coach I don't say it
on TV
but when I'm talking to Clark I'm
selling candy and earning and great I'm
saying like these guys can't coach your
lick because what I have noticed these
coaches make no in-game adjustments like
some of these coaches are great but some
of coach Dunn family it's got can coach
he only has columns and that's why you
see you know I'm watching a strategy of
the game but you can see who could like
in an NBA game in a series I'm game one
the game for there are so many
adjustments back and forth like you can
find out who can really coach and who
can really play and so March Madness is
pretty easy like I like the matchups I
love to see the team like one team's
always like a lot of teams like okay
they might be a lot better but man when
a guys are pretty soon 55 45 something
like that and then a coach can base of
adjustments I love watching the Strad
of that oh yeah you know and now it
seems like you know no less Rhea r16
being a one with the one bit of the
three-point shot if a team is not
superior more talented you're gonna have
more and more upset you know become
three-point shot you get a bunch of guys
you can shoot please and you get a team
this like don't have as Ireland or berry
or British like now we got like oh now
we don't have some upset once to me the
best things about March Madness
I love the city great coaches maker
judges and they is awesome to watch but
I make fun of the coaches you can't
coach we've had some games where a team
would run the same play like five times
in a row ride and get a layup or easy
shot every time but I'm like clearly a
sense of time they're gonna make it
adjustment right no they just don't do
it I'll make they ran to same place five
times I got a shot every time our
easiest shot so your alma mater
yesterday comes through for the SEC but
dominating the Tennessee Volunteers get
a five seed open up against New Mexico
State what team or teams do you think
has the best chance at winning this
national championship is there a handful
teams or is there or can you narrow it
down to a few that you really think I've
only got a real shot well Duke it's a
prohibitive favorite you know Coach K is
amazing but Zion and those guys they're
too prohibitive favorite well let me
tell you something a local periodic
Gonzaga I think Tennessee is interesting
because they got a bunch of older guys
who are physically and you don't need
some big so do kind of Duke is only
gonna get these five fifteen they don't
have to be physically manhandle get down
and foul trouble I think there's only
church
that's the testing all the chance of
losing I think Enzo is a great great
coat so they got a chance I'm trying to
think but I think there's five or
seventeen spotty stuff but Duke is the
favorite I like he's tremendously / I do
I think Kevin Sampson is it's been
coaching he's been in the NBA and
college a long time I think he can make
adjustments a mile actually got beat on
a minute by Michigan and I don't wanna
leave I miss that guy
he might be the most underrated coach in
college basketball cookie line I mean he
what he does you're out every year with
the player he loses to the NBA and he
comes back and is loaded again but I
think I said that I think there's about
five or six cool but do pick a favorite
well Charles I want to say thank you
Charles Barkley here Basketball Hall of
Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst being
rented out this week in the next for the
NCAA tournament I appreciate you doing
this for me pal it was so great to talk
to you again I know we've been meaning
to to catch up for some time now but I
just wanted to really say thanks again
for for joining us today I want to thank
you for having me and I want to tell you
that I'm so happy and good and I'm proud
of you and just keep doing your thing my
brother I appreciate that
Charles Berkeley everybody Basketball
Hall of Famer Turner Sports NBA analysts
Basketball Hall of Fame 2010 class the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience